[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the leaked Avengers
what if trailer footage from d23 I've
talked a little bit about the series
before so we'll break it all down we
have a whole bunch of new details and
we're doing a new round of the Disney
Plus streaming service giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite what if story on
the video what do you want them to do
what if Wolverine fought Thanos during
Avengers endgame what if general Ross
became the Red Hulk instead of Bruce
Banner becoming the green version of the
Hulk we got information on about six
episodes including what's going on with
spider-man during the series they'll be
23 episodes total one for each of the
movies in the MCU so far so that
includes spider-man homecoming in
spider-man far from home as well as
using spider-man in the ones that they
do for Avengers infinity war and
Avengers end game and Captain America
Civil War the whole idea is that you
have the watcher narrating the series
the same way that he narrates a lot of
Marvel Comics Marvel what-if is a
long-running comic series Jeffrey Wright
is gonna be there watcher they announced
him at the Comic Con panel he'll be
narrating all the episodes as the main
version of The Watcher in every once in
a while he'll step out of the shadows to
interact with the characters in the
episodes maybe not every single episode
because it's really special and really
rare that the watcher ever speaks to any
of the Marvel characters it's actually
been a while since that's happened in
the comics if you're a longtime fan of
agents of shield they did an episode
inspired by the Marvel what-if series
where they all got stuck inside this
mainframe and live this alternate
reality within the computer mainframe
but technically it wasn't a real what-if
story because it was all happening
inside a simulation instead of actually
happening to the characters in reality
so breaking down the six episodes that
we had footage for number six the Black
Panther episode what if Black Panther
became star-lord technically it would be
what if T'Challa became star-lord
because I think in this scenario just
looking at the footage here he's wearing
star Lords uniform he's probably not
also wearing the mantle of Black Panther
during this scenario because this would
be a situation where his father winds up
being ego the Living Planet he visits
earth his mother is still from Wakanda
but then you have to imagine him during
the plot of the original guardians of
the galaxy movie where you have the
route
coming to pick up a young version of
Peter quill take him to space and he
grows up with the Ravagers so you have a
version of T'Challa black panther
growing up with the Ravagers he's
wearing star-lords helmet it looks like
he's on Morag here at the beginning of
the events of the first guardians of the
galaxy movie to steal the Power Stone so
that sounds wildly different but because
it's a black panther episode kill monger
is also coming back and starring in it
meaning that if Black Panther wasn't
there to become Black Panther during the
events of the Black Panther movie that
means the kill monger is probably able
to come back take the mantle seize
Wakanda and then use their vibranium to
take over the world just like his plan
was during the Black Panther movie even
though all the what-if stories don't
always have a downer ending that does
sound like a bit of a downer ending for
planet Earth darkest timeline earth even
while star-lord touch ala is playing
around in the Stars having fun with the
guardians of the galaxy team a lot of
you also noticed that the animation
style looks very similar to the
animation style on Iron Man armored
adventures but that cel-shaded animation
I think this is going to be a little bit
more premium than that number 5 there's
a Captain America First Avenger episode
I believe that's even supposed to be the
very first episode of the series
what if Peggy Carter got the Super
Soldier Serum and became
Captain America our version of Captain
America in what if skinny Steve Rogers
got a big Ironman suit designed by
Howard Stark they're bringing back young
Howard Stark Arnim Zola dr. Erskine for
that episode this is all going to be
half hour animation so you have to
imagine them condensing the plot of
Captain America First Avenger into a
half hour episode so the first little
bit of the episode plays almost exactly
like the events of the first Captain
America movie she's the one that goes
into the device gets the Super Soldier
Serum but when she comes out because
she's British
they call her Captain Britain she wears
the Captain Britain comic book costume
remember there was a Captain Britain
Easter egg during Avengers end game
during the Peggy Carter 1970s scene she
mentions an agent Braddock Braddock is
Captain Britain in the comics so even
though the what-if series is sort of
like an else world story like what if
things were different technically not
canon to the MCU within the actual
real cannon of the MCU there was the
captain Britain we just don't know what
he was doing running around during the
1970s but this is trailer footage from
what it's actually going to look like
during this series so like you see
skinny Rogers in this giant Iron Monger
tank looking Iron Man suit is world war
two so of course the suit would look
like an actual tank because Howard Stark
probably just repurposes an actual tank
to make the suit the rest of the episode
plays out very similar to what the plot
of the original Captain America movie
was although I don't know if they're
gonna get Hugo Weaving to come back
because remember Ross Marquand is now
the new version of Red Skull inside the
MCU
because Hugo Weaving did not want to
come back in Avengers infinity war in
Avengers endgame they didn't say why so
entertain whatever conspiracy theory you
want maybe he just didn't want to do Red
Skull anymore
but we do have a version of Red Skull
and Ross mark and he's mostly known from
The Walking Dead so he does a lot of TV
I think it's pretty easy to get him to
come back to do more red skull inside
the what-if series the showrunners of
the what-if series actually did an
interview at d23 talking a little bit
about the dynamic of what's going on
during these episodes the most
surprising thing for a lot of the actors
has been they're getting to play aspects
of their characters that they would
never get to do in the MCU
and even though we just talked about a
guardians of the galaxy black panther
episode number four because there's one
for every single MCU movie there is a
what-if episode for both guardians of
the galaxy movies with number four
Thanos coming back fragglan Korra Theon
do taser faces coming back so that's
probably a version of events where ego
the Living Planet might be successful
because the whole idea is that Peter
quill is able to stand against his
father and say no I'm gonna stay with
the family that I made for myself not
the family that I was born with imagine
a version of Peter quill that completely
embraced his cosmic abilities and his
celestial heritage I know that a lot of
questions about how those worked and why
he didn't use his powers later the whole
idea is that being half celestial gives
him a vastly expanded lifespan even
without cosmic powers he still will live
longer he won't get sick like other
people but the closer he gets to ego the
Living Planet the more powerful he gets
he was at his most powerful when they
were standing right next to his brain so
because ego died or seemingly died
during that movie because there's a
question of whether or not you can
actually really kill him all of Peter
Quill's greater celestial abilities
basically went away so he seems more
like a normal person but 50% of his DNA
is still celestial so he still will live
longer than normal humans 3 there's a
Thor episode Loki Thor Korg
the Grand Master and Jane Foster Nick
Fury are coming back because all these
Marvel phase 4 TV shows are meant to
crossover and set up what's going on in
the movies I assumed that the Thor
episode is just meant to set up the
concept of Jane Foster Thor from an
alternate reality or whether it's going
to be Jane Foster in our reality that
wields the hammer they haven't really
been clear about that because
technically there is no Mjolnir in the
main universe of the MCU right now they
took the one that they had during
endgame back to Thor the dark world so
there is no Mjolnir in present day so
the only way you get Mjolnir in present
day is if Loki from the alternate
reality brings one in traveling from
that place but they haven't said much
about what's going on with hella or
whether or not Kate Blanchet is going to
come back she did say that she wants to
come back but if there's gonna be 23
episodes then the 20-something MCU
actors that they announced publicly at
comic-con are probably just a fraction
of the actual MCU actors that will be
coming to do the episodes the series is
going to premiere summer 2021 and we get
Thor for love and thunder that November
so they might just double up on episodes
they've done it for a lot of other
animated series in the past where they
released a block of episodes every
single week instead of just one episode
- we know about the ant-man episode they
didn't say whether it's ant-man the wasp
or it's the original ant-man movie but
ant-man Hank Pym in the ex-con team are
coming back like what if they had gotten
stuck in the quantum realm what if Hank
Pym had continued to wear the ant-man
suit instead of passing it off to Scott
Lang in the first movie what if Janet
Van Dyne had come out of the quantum
realm sooner what if hope had warned the
ant-man suit during the events of the
first movie because it's animation I
also expect them to get into way more
quantum realm stuff because it's way
cheaper for them to do those crazy
special effects when they're animating
it but probably the biggest episode that
they leaked trailer footage of is number
one Marvel Zombies you see the scene of
Winter Soldier in present day getting
ready to fight
zombie Captain America if you're not a
big comic book fan or you're not
familiar with the concept of Marvel
Zombies that's
dori from Marvel Comics done by Robert
Kirkman of walking dead faint big
surprise he does zombies stories he does
a Marvel Zombies story where zombie Reed
Richards tricks his ultimate universe
counterpart Reed Richards into opening a
portal to the zombie universe or the
reality where everyone has become a
zombie allowing them into the ultimate
universe after which you can guess what
happened all the zombies start consuming
all the regular versions of the
characters in the Ultimate Universe
meanwhile zombies decide that the flesh
of other zombies isn't just as
satisfying so Galactus shows up because
this is a big Fantastic Four story
eventually the zombies are able to wear
him down consume him steal his lifeforce
empowering them with cosmic level
abilities they set out to the Stars to
Galactus style consume everything in
sight because the series isn't coming
for a couple years it is possible for
them to use Fantastic Four x-men mutant
concepts during this and while I was
making my spider-man video yesterday it
was actually discovered that the reason
why Marvel can still use spider-man in
this series is because Marvel has the TV
rights for half-hour animation that's
why most of the spider-man TV series so
far have come from Marvel and not from
Sony so because all these what-if
episodes are half-hour animation they
can do whatever they want to with
spider-man I don't know if they're
allowed to use Tom Holland though or if
that signed a new contract for that or
get another actor to be the voice of
spider-man in these episodes the same
way that they got Ross mark and to be
the red skull during Avengers infinity
war and Avengers endgame the very first
Marvel phase 4 series that's gonna drop
will be Falcon in Winter Soldier and
that'll be next fall not this year but
next year the what-if series is gonna
drop summer 2021 so we'll probably get
some more footage at Comic Con next year
maybe some other stuff will leak out
before then if it does I will totally do
a video for it but let me know in the
comments which what-if stories do you
want them to do and the ideas that
they'll continue to do new episodes so
when we get the Marvel phase 4 movies
Marvel phase 5 phase 6 they'll do new
seasons of what-if with episodes for
each of those brand new movies there's a
couple new Marvel videos that I'm
working on while you guys wait for that
you can click here for my non-spoilery
joker movie review and you can click
here for my breakdown of that Fantastic
Four Comic Con
Teezer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]